I went into the dressing room to talk to
you beforehand and possibly see you
naked and it's a thing I do to put my
guests at ease
no I person to your dressing room and we
were talking and we started talking
about road trips yes I didn't know this
yeah I haven't done it in a while but I
used to love to take road trips and I
understand that's the thing of yours to
you you love taking a road trip
I do love road trips but I like to take
road trips and I treat them like extreme
sports like I like a really crazy road
trip like just describe what that means
I mean we I took a road trip once with a
few friends and we rode small 150 cc
Vespas from Los Angeles to the bottom of
the Florida Keys with nothing more than
we could strap to the vest was like
tents sleeping bags that's and we didn't
pay for lodging once wait a minute okay
so you broke into motels and stayed
there illegally no no that's what that
means to me when I didn't pay for
lodging that doesn't mean I camped out
that means I broke into the ice hotels
by the way because of all these hearings
going on I now know to say no definitely
not
yeah yeah but we did end up sleeping in
the backyard of an abandoned house at
one point because we had these rules
like you couldn't you couldn't spend any
money to sleep anywhere so you had to
either account on the hospitality of
strangers which was kind of like shady
sometimes sheriff or sleep wherever you
could here's my question the vest for
you describe yeah that's loaded up with
equipment and stuff like that with that
tiny little engine that they take from
an egg beater yeah yeah I'm guessing
that's a top speed of what if you're on
a highway is that like 3540 miles an
hour oh yeah you're not going on
highways
yeah no way you're on like small roads
like I mean with all the gear you could
probably hit 50 if you had like a nice
tailwind and a downhill yeah yeah how
many people put a sail on their Vespa
desperate times
okay so you're driving around you see
lots of when you take a road trip you
see a lot of fascinating things and you
you said you brought a picture I have
not seen this but you brought a picture
something you saw that sort of tickled
your fancy a little bit yeah you know
you you find weird things when you're
out on the road and I recently took a
road trip kind of along route 66 for a
little bit and yeah you just you find
odd things great shops great shops my
only regret was that I actually got
there after let's take a look at this
picture it is fetishes
and earring yeah what do you think is
happening there I missed it by about
half an hour and I'm so pissed what do
you think that could be Andy you've been
there what's it like now well when they
say fetishes that's that's a Native
American it's like a native Amer
like it's like they're sniffing your
feet in that place right you know it's
like then I will never go there but but
we now know what Andy's fetish is you
just reveal I used to love taking road
trips and I would do the same thing I
would try to drive as long as I could
without going to the bathroom oh yeah
it's a big thing with me and how are can
you get on your gas tank before you have
to before you look the depends on what
I'm driving yeah oh but for a while
there I had like I had a 1973 Plymouth
Valiant okay and those things does alas
they're pushed forward by shooting
gasoline on the back yes a great force
and that's what propels the car yeah I
got I got a truck that I drive when I do
my road trips and I like if I'm by
myself and I don't have anyone who's
like hey can we stop like that kind of
thing I try to get a minimum of three
quarters of a tank of gas before I stop
to go to the bathroom right which is
along you can also there are a lot of
ways to go to the bathroom in the car
and I don't want to get specific but I
think you all know what I'm talking
about
I'm curious because I have no idea what
you're talking about on old cars there's
an ashtray
I thought this is something everyone was
with me on yeah
curly I went too far I actually took a
road trip once with my brother this
wasn't and this is while I had this show
and I took a road trip and I stopped off
at an A&W we were in Montana oh yeah we
stopped off at a named an A&W Root Beer
like fast food place and we ate there
and they recognized me and so I they you
know they wanted pictures and stuff and
they were really nice and I think that
was really nice to them and I left and
then later on they put up a sign you
know they have those signs that you can
put up a message they put up a message
and what I loved about this message was
the spelling of my name and that it's
kind of I know what they meant but the
way they phrased it wasn't quite right
and I have a picture of it they sent me
thanks for stopping conan o'brien their
desperate need of a combo yeah yeah I
know they just won ,
I sent it to them but it made me really
happy it made me think like and I'm sure
other like truckers were driving by it
was a pretty remote but I'm sure they're
like well I'm glad someone did stop
[Laughter]
[Music]
you